I don't know if you've heard about this
is a real story some Tea Party groups in
Tennessee want school textbooks
rewritten so that the books overlook the
founding fathers history of owning
slaves that's right this is a getting a
lot of attention this story they want to
remove references to the founding
fathers being slave owners so that
they'll be portrayed only in a positive
light we'll hear now to talk about this
further is one of our writers mr. Dion
call beyond
thanks Conan so the Tennessee Tea Party
wants to erase an overlook all the
negative things that slave on its ditch
african-american people in order to
shine a light on them so they'll look
good
okay Tea Party we will in a white away
all the negative in your textbooks and
forget about everything your slave on
and forefathers done if you agree to
overlook these things for us like Milli
Vanilli Omarosa Flavor Flav the DC
sniper the OJ trial
Basketball Wives season one Basketball
Wives season two Basketball Wives season
three
Basketball Wives the reunion show Tiger
Woods our Kelly Herman Cain Isaiah
Washington Barry Bonds all black people
being late all black people talking to
movie theaters all black B we eatin
chicken in public black people eating
any kind of fruit that ends in melon
black people not tipping pie a West ego
Chris Brown Bobby Brown well I am
clothing choice Flavor Flav again Al
Sharpton's here Don King's here dr.
Cornel West hair Mike Tyson my Rick
white Michael Jackson
and the movie so play
nice so do you have a deal yes we have a
deal Dion call her
[Applause]